i'm concerned
i'm deeply concerned about the
smartphone market because to me
i think apple has a monopoly i'm an
apple guy by the way i got an email from
a guy yesterday
when we when we bashed apple this guy
sent an email okay
who was and i want to i want to read
this on full disclosure and i'm going to
give him a shout out because i told him
i want to share this
he says that's fine he sent the email he
says i'm a former apple employee
okay he says as a former apple employee
i think they donate tons and tons of
money no
questions asked anytime i donated a
charitable organization apple matched it
i forget what the limit was on that but
it was pretty high
if i volunteered my time to a charitable
organization
apple would pay 30 an hour to work
for a charitable organization this is a
guy saying this to me craig c
okay who said this about apple so i want
to say that to apple if that's the case
if there's anybody else that's working
for apple or ever worked at apple that
can validate that story that happened to
you as well
i want to give the proper shout out to
these guys if that's the case okay
so now but i do have a concern i think
the number one monopoly right now in
america is
apple and it comes down to the
smartphone game
monopoly is 50 plus right we talked
about is that thing on the last
last podcast briefly with tom and i said
let's get the stats so
what percentage of phones american use
is iphone
what percentage is another phone what do
you think it is because you got samsung
i can't even i could only name two
samsung and apple and i'm just basing
this on
the people i know and the phones i see
i'm going to say it's 74 apple
74. what do you think hold on hold on
we're saying that fifty percent is a
monopoly
yeah and
what percentage of americans using apple
you said seventy i'm using i'm gonna
i'm gonna just start the the two more
minutes what do you think it is
i don't think it's a monopoly yet
because i think it would be more in the
news
but it's damn close i'm saying something
in the low 40s 40s
40s okay all right i don't know the
number but i have to say it's more than
50 percent
i'm gonna say it's 50 i'm 60 is what i'm
going to say 55 60 percent
let's go to the data i'm curious drum
roll please what do we got here
what is the number got it
wow okay well listen good for them
what are we 45 then they're not a
monopoly okay
45 percent i said they were dangerous
watch this
but watch watch the number 42 3 43 3 43
5 44 2 45 1 45 2 45 3 45 4
45 yeah it's not looking good for
anybody else and our blackberry and our
blackberry is
out the game and blackberry is doing
what blackberry's the uh
uh uh what's the thing about blackbeard
black spike's record 65
after finalizing the old amazon for
automotive data software blackberry
surge at
you know there's their software called
iv allows automakers to read vehicle
sensor data and improve systems and
performance according to press release
the stocks leap is its biggest one-day
gain on record and places shares at
their highest level since april
2019. blackberry was known as a cell
phone company now they're selling
intel intelligent vehicle data platform
yeah
so my concern is if apple has got 45.3
how many more years till they cross that
50 or do you think tim cook
intentionally keeps it below 50 percent
it's kind of like the app store like
you know he's that they were at 30 fee
and they they reduced it to 15 percent
he does not want to cross right now
right there's the rest of the world that
you can work on the numbers yeah right
he does
not want to crack that 50 number it's
kind of like we said yesterday that
that amazon is rooting for target yes
apple is probably rooting come on
blackberry
come on samsung they're coming out with
a new phone right samsung
i mean apple's strategy is you need a
new one every year so that you don't
need to be over 50.